Short and sweet review number four. We discussed a case where either a person had accidentally put a meat spoon or meat ladle inside of a dairy pot, and inside the pot was yad soledes bo, water or soup, and or similarly, a same case would be if there was a par of soup inside of a pot or hot water inside of a pot, a par of pot, but a meat and dairy spoon were both put in at the same time. Both of these cases are the same halachically.
Exactly. If one of those utensils, the meat or the dairy utensil, whether it be the spoon or the pot or both spoons, if they have residue on them, so then we're not really dealing with a not-bar-not issue, because we're dealing with residue. Residue is never subject to not-bar-not, it's the actual food. And therefore, a person would have to figure out if there's shishim against the residue, if it's both of a shishim or not. If it is, then we can disregard the residue. However, if there is not 60 times, then we have to deal with the fact that there is an actual meat or dairy inside of this pot.
We'll focus primarily on a situation where both of them are clean.
Both the pot and the spoon, or both spoons in the second case, are both clean.
So if they're both clean, and they're both benyomo,
so then we are in a situation where we have two clean utensils of different types
mixing inside of a par of water or a par of soup.
That would be, in a situation like that, it would be a machlokas between the Shulchan Aruch and the Rama.
The Shulchan Aruch would hold everything is permitted, and this is a case of not-burnat,
While the Rama would hold everything is prohibited because the flavors mix together in the liquid.
In a situation where both of those, Kalim, both utensils were not benyoma, they have not been used in the past 24 hours,
and again, they're both clean, everybody agrees that the utensils are permitted.
However, the Rama says the water should be discarded because water is cheap.
We can always throw that out.
If it's a soup, which is something that cannot be discarded so easily,
then even the Rama agrees that the food can be eaten, the soup can be eaten.
Let's say a situation where one was benyoma and one was not benyoma.
Again, they're both clean.
In this scenario, again, everyone agrees, the Shulchan Aruch and Rama both agree that everything is permitted.
If it's a question of the contents of the pot, if it's water, again, the Rama says you should discard the water.
Water is cheap, but if it's a soup, the soup can be eaten.
In a situation where we're not putting one type of utensil onto another, but we're dealing with the case of pouring,
let's say pouring a par of soup from a meat benyomo pot onto a clean dairy benyomo bowl.
So then we discuss that in this situation of pouring, where it's lo nisach ha'kiluach, there's an actual stream going from the pot into the bowl, we view it as if the bowl is inside of the pot.
Well, that's only the bowl is inside the pot, but not the pot is inside of the bowl.
So in this scenario, for sure the pot is going to be permitted, we view it as completely disconnected from the bowl.
But the question is, what is the status of the bowl?
So the Rama holds that the dairy bowl would be forbidden, it was viewed as if it was actually dipped into the Fleshik pot, however, the liquid will be permitted for various reasons.
The Shach held that everything is permitted, and the Chochmas Adam said, kind of a midway, if it's not a big loss, then the plate would be forbidden, however, in the case of a loss of money, we would permit the plate like the Shach.
In a situation where a person inserted a fleshyk utensil into a parv pot and then took it out,
and then inserted a dairy utensil into the same pot after the fleshyk utensil was removed,
again, in a situation where they're both clean, even if they're both benyomo,
everything is permitted because it was done consecutively, they were not in the pot at the same time.
There are magos so far to say that also in a situation of a klisheni,
If let's say you have a pot, which was a pot of water that you cooked up, and then you pour that water into a cold bowl, and then you dumped into that cold bowl, two different types of utensils, a fleshik and a dairy, even if they were dirty, and they had residue on them, since it's in a klisheni, the Rama holds a klisheni does not transfer flavor and everything is permitted, you would rinse them off in cold water, and they would not need to be koshered.
In a situation also where let's say a person poured hot water from a klirishon, this is a case what we call eroy klirishon, so then the Rama said even if it's, as long as it's eroy klirishon, pouring from a klirishon, that also does not transfer flavor, and even if a person would pour boiling hot water from a klirishon onto dairy, sorry, dirty meat and dairy dishes, everything is still permitted.
Because of all these factors of klisheni and because of iroi klirishon, the Ramab says if a person finds a clean meat utensil in their dairy utensil drawer, everything is permitted and vice versa.
Because there are so many factors that are in play and so many spheikos, so many doubts, a person would not have to kasher that utensil.
Then we discuss a ladle. We discuss a machlokas, whether or not a ladle, when you scoop out from a pot, has a status of a klirishon or does it have a status of a klisheni.
Everyone agrees though, if it's sat in the pot for long enough to heat up, it does take on the status of a klirishon.
We also discussed the status of hot water coming out of a sink. That was a big machlokes.
We saw the Shemir Shabbos Gilchasa held that the hot water coming out of a sink has a status of klirishon, which goes k'dek klipa.
The Menchas Yitzchak said it has a higher level of eroy klirishon. It's eroy klirishon al ha'esh, because the boiler has the fire on, which is the same as a klirishon as well.
And the Or Litzion was the most lenient of the opinions.
He said it's considered E-Rekli Sheni because of the pipes cool off the water,
and it would only be E-Rekli Sheni, which cannot transfer flavor and cannot make any problems with dishes.
We also then would discuss the discussion of sinks, how many sinks a person should have.
It's always ideal to have separate sinks for meat and dairy.
If a person only has one sink, so then there was an opinion that said you can still use it for both meat and dairy.
The Menchas Yitzchak said a person should have a separate rack and a separate bin and should wash out the sink.
Rav Moshe said that a person only needs a separate rack, but not a separate bin, and Rabelski said you only need a separate bin, well, you don't need a separate rack, but again, the Chachila person should have separate sinks for meat and dairy.